how do you gauge the philanthropic  motives of a donor is it through what  they tell in conversation is about about  what type of careers they pursue how do  you gauge how honorable their motives  are I think you through conversation is  how you determine this best and as I  said through a long-standing  relationship you know over a long time  you know they get to know us with all  the things that we might not be so happy  having out there but we also get to know  them and it's like with our relationship  with friends you know you get to know  them even so you know you couldn't  exactly tell where you exactly you know  figured out where they are but you know  it is important that you know  philanthropy you know be exercised or  that we call philanthropy what  philanthropy truly is and not marketing  is not vilandra p you know getting  visibility getting you know something  for it